what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and black clover may
have just revealed the identity of
osta's father in an absolutely insane
chapter this was so unexpected and there
are so many big reveals to talk about
there is a fourth zogradus sibling
osta's father may have been a childhood
friend of xenon the name of xenon's
devil is now confirmed this was crazy
let's get into it if you enjoy the black
lore content on this channel and you
want us to keep it going you know what
to do just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
really helps with the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain black lover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned we left off last time with
yuno unlocking a new spell wind spirit
creation magic spirit of euros which of
course allowed him to manifest a large
and majestic bow and arrow juno was
convinced that just one attack from this
bow and arrow could defeat xenon xenon
was looking pretty worried and that is
how the chapter ended after reading that
chapter i was not expecting that the
next chapter would be this insane and
that this much crucial information would
be revealed at the very beginning of the
new chapter eunozero lands a hit on
xenon and it tears straight through his
chest xenon is shocked by the speed and
power of juno's attack and he can't
believe that his overpowered
devil-possessed body could be pierced
clean through in this way as yuno boldly
declares victory over xenon which may or
may not have been premature we get an
unexpectedly important flashback to
xenon's childhood we learned that as a
child xenon was bullied and because he
wasn't strong enough to defend himself
from the bullies his older siblings
dante and manika mocked him it is then
revealed that a fourth zogradus sibling
exists xenon had another older brother
apart from dante a brother who was in a
wheelchair unlike dante and ranika this
brother was actually kind to xenon and
he told them that the two of them are
actually alike according to the elder
brother even though xenon was frail on
the outside he had more potential to
become stronger through devil possession
than both dante and vanica this revealed
that a fourth zograda sibling exists is
quite massive with all three dark triad
members seemingly defeated or close to
being defeated at this point in the
story we've all been wondering who will
be the next major villain aside from the
cliff-off devils and possibly morris the
spade kingdom war arc is obviously not
over yet yami and william have not been
rescued so there is no chance that the
arc is going to end with the defeat of
dante vanika and xenon but is this
fourth sibling still alive and could he
be the true villain of the spade kingdom
ark could he be the one who possesses
the time magic devil that is said to be
residing on the lowest floor of the
underworld earlier on in the story we
learned that there are three major
devils on the lowest floor of the
underworld and that they have gravity
magic spatial magic and time magic we
know that dante's devil has gravity
magic xenon's devil has spatial magic
but vanica's devil megikula has curse
warding magic not time magic this may be
because the time magic devil already
possessed their eldest brother the 4th
zogradus sibling i can't wait to find
out more about this mysterious fourth
sibling especially because he seems to
be the one who was pushing his siblings
to become devil hosts so it is likely
that he has more experience with dark
magic and devil magic than the rest of
them he could be the one orchestrating
everything behind the scenes and he
could be binding his time and waiting
for the right moment to reveal himself
or he could already be dead we can't
know for sure but i'm definitely excited
to find out more about this eldest
brother
now in the xenon flashback we see a
young xenon being bullied by the other
kids because of how creepy his bone
magic looks but then another boy appears
and this boy saves xenon from the
bullies he says so what if his magic is
different and once the bullies run away
he introduces himself to xenon the boy's
name is alan and he looks a lot and i
mean a lot like asta and not only does
this allen guy look a lot like costa he
also acts like asta and has similar
ambitions he wants to protect the people
and help his country which is currently
facing numerous forms of hardships from
harsh climates to frequent wars alan
wants to save the people by becoming the
commanding officer of the mage defense
force which seems to be the spate
kingdom's equivalent of the wizard king
little xenon then declares that he also
wants to become the wizard king or i
mean the commanding officer of the mage
defense force and the two kids xenon and
alan become friendly rivals the
parallels between these two and yuno and
asta are very clear and very deliberate
throughout the chapter the two boys
spend the next few years training and
after they receive their grimoires xenon
tells his brother that he is no longer
interested in becoming a devil host
instead he and allen joined the fourth
division of the mage defense forces soon
after they join a new dungeon appears
within the spade kingdom and xenon and
allen along with other mages are sent
out on an official mission to explore
the dungeon unfortunately this was no
ordinary dungeon an actual devil was
sealed inside of it and many of the
defense force members who were sent to
the dungeon lost their lives because of
this overpowered devil despite having
powerful magic himself xenon isn't fast
enough to strike the devil with his bone
magic and so alan has to step in allen
attacks the devil with what looks like a
flaming claymore sword made out of fire
magic and the fact that alan uses a
giant sword is just another of many
blatant and intentional similarities to
osta as alan struggles with the devil
xenon knows that if he aims his spell at
the devil now he will succeed in killing
him however if he does that then alan
will die along with the devil so it is a
horrible choice that xenon has to make
if he waits for alan to move out of the
way then the devil will be impossible to
hit but if alan stays where he is then
he will perish alongside the devil alan
is xenon's cherished childhood friend
and his rival so xenon absolutely does
not want to hurt him in any way but at
the same time if they fail to stop the
devil here he will not only kill all the
members of the mage defense force here
in the dungeon he will also go on to
kill everyone in the nearby village and
who knows how many other innocent people
before someone finally stops him as
members of the mage defense force
defending the citizens of the spade
kingdom is their job and their duty and
so they can't just let thousands of
innocent civilians die in order to save
themselves because of that xenon makes
the difficult decision to shoot his bone
magic through allen's body in order to
get to the devil and while this succeeds
in defeating the devil it also seems to
kill alan at the same time xenon is
devastated by the choice that he had to
make and the panel immediately after
allen's apparent death shows xenon
sobbing uncontrollably with pure
devastation on his face and pure misery
in his eyes
after this traumatic experience xenon
became disillusioned with the philosophy
that he and alan had followed the belief
that commitment and persistence alone
were enough to accomplish their lofty
goals xenon ultimately concludes that
all of the things that he and alan had
relied on were meaningless without
strength and so in order to gain more
strength and avoid this type of
situation from ever happening again
xenon goes back to his brother and
agrees to become a devil host the
chapter ends with the reveal of xenon's
devil's name beelzebub
whoa
we've been waiting so long for the
reveal of xenon's devil's name and now
that we've gotten it it's only like the
third craziest reveal in this chapter
even more insane is the reveal that
there is another zogradus sibling out
there somewhere a sibling who appears to
have been orchestrating this whole devil
possession family business that the
sogratus clan has been engaging in and
of course we have the reveal of allen a
man who is so similar to osta in both
appearance and behavior that he has to
be related to him in some way and of
course many are speculating that this is
osta's father i personally find it
almost impossible that alan wouldn't be
related to asta in some meaningful way
after how strongly the similarities
between the two of them were emphasized
in this chapter alan being asked his
father would definitely be the most
dramatic and impactful option although i
guess he could technically be some other
type of relation to hosta like maybe his
uncle allen does kind of look like
lychitas so i guess he could be
legitimate's brother but the father
angle just makes a lot more sense from a
story perspective alan being austa's
father would explain why lychita ended
up alone after becoming pregnant with
asta seeing the type of person that
allen is i can totally imagine him
defending lichita from people who
bullied her because of the nature of her
magic just like they bullied xenon and
some sort of encounter of this type
could have led to lychita and alan
falling in love allen was definitely the
type of guy who would defend lichita and
stand up for her no matter what kind of
magic she possessed but if alan died
while she was still pregnant with asta
he would no longer have been able to
protect her from the people who hated
her because of her magic and so lichita
may have been forced to leave the spade
kingdom and settle on the outskirts of
the clover kingdom where no one knew her
or her magic
alan being austa's father would explain
a lot in my opinion and i mean the
similarities between the two of them are
just too drastic to ignore but we'll
have to wait and see i am definitely
leaning towards alan being asked as
father at this point in time and if he
doesn't turn out to be austa's father
i'm like 99 sure that he will end up
being connected to asta in some other
important way all of these similarities
between the two of them are not a
coincidence but let me know what you
guys think about this absolutely insane
chapter is alan asta's father osta's
uncle or is he connected to asta in some
other way also who is this eldest
sokratis sibling and is he still alive
could he be the secret mastermind of
this entire war arc
finally did this older zagrada's brother
actually orchestrate the devil incident
inside the dungeon in order to get rid
of alan and manipulate xenon into
becoming a devil host don't forget to
hit me up with your thoughts down in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this blacklover video and
you want to see more black lover content
right here on the channel please leave a
quick like to let me know it only takes
a second but it helps a lot and if
you're new to anime uproar or maybe you
watch our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting that bell and then
selecting the option that says all if
you don't do that you're still gonna
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i wanna give a
quick thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thank you to alpha
sigma he is an absolute mad lad and
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata pate
heffer algetal hinokamien water the
toasted chi the spike dylan issador
spidey life chanel tungsten tarcus big
buddhist and monkey d quilly finally
thank you to all of our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red haired raven angel
crews rather very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks joanne garcia ted no ted
fat boy games corey mcgowan and soul ray
slice and dice if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patreon exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you